عاشت البرازيل ساعات صعبه بعد اعمال شغب
وفوض وصفت بانها اسوا هجوم على مؤسسه
البلاد منذ 40 عاما عشرات الالف من
المتظاهرين من مناصر يا رئيس البرازيلي
السابق جير بورسونارو اقتحموا المحكمه
العليا والكونغرس والقصر الرئاسي وحطم
نوافذ وقلب الاثاث ودمروا اعمالا فنيه
وسرقوا النسخه الاصليه لدكتور البلاد لعام
1988 كما تم الاستلاء على بناتها من مكتب
لامن الرئاسه وبعد ساعه من الاشتباكات
استعاده الشرطه السيطره على المباني
الحكوميه كما نشرت السلطات البرازيليه
المئات من قوات الجيش في الشوارع الرئيسيه
وامام المقر الحكوميه رئيس البرازيلي لولا
دا سيلفا تعهد بالعفور على الجناه
وبمعاقبتهم كما اعلنت تدخل امنيا
الاتحاديه في العاصمه البرازيليه حتى
نهايه الشهر عليه
زينت سبينس
والاعتقالات في حاله التلبس مستمره لانه
عمليا يحدث التلبس اثناء ارتكاب جريمه او
بعد ذلك بوقت قصير
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من برازيلي
الصحفي هندرستاني اهلا بك من اورلاندو توم
حرب ريس وتحالف الامريكي يشرق اساطير
الديمقراطيه اهلا بكم
من برازيليه معك هاني هاني
ما يحدث في البرازيل خاصه بعد متابعه
الاحتجاجات ليس فقط التي بدات في التوسع
ولكن كذلك الاشتياحات المستمره المحكمه
العليا الكونجرس القصر الرئاسي هل هناك
نيه لمحاوله الدفع باعاده الانتخابات هل
هي الفوضى ما الذي يحدث بالتحديد
مساء الخير لحضرتك الكريم
ما يحدث في البرازيل هو حقيقه صدمه عاشها
جميع البرازيليه خوفا من عوده ايام
الديكتاتوريه والانقلاب على الديمقراطيه
وعلى الشرعيه في الشارع ما حصل بالامس
عباره عن تحول من تظاهره
اعتيادي كانت ضمن النشاطات التي غضب عليها
انصار الرئيس
الانتخابيه وكان من المقرر لها ان تكون
مظاهره سلميه ثم تحولت الى مظاهره عفوا
الى اقتحامات والى تفسير
هل كانت هناك يعني البعض يستبعد ان تكون
هذه الاستراحات المتراكمه عمليه تلقائيه
هل هناك دفع بشيء معين في داخل البرازيلي
البعض المؤشرات تقول بانها من قاعده تلك
المظاهره بالتحديد هم انصار من اليمين
المتطرفين امريكا
من قبل رجال الامن الذين كان بهم حمايه
تلك الممتلكات العامه الهدف من كل هذا
الامر هو الدعوه للغاء طبعا نتائج
الانتخابات التي صدرت في نهايه السنه امم
طيب ورئيس لولا ده سيلفا يقول بانه
سيتعاقب وسيحاسب كل المتورطين في هذه
الاحتجاجات وفي هذه الاجتهاد كذلك ولكن
وهنا سؤال حضرتك استاذ توم لماذا في ظل ما
تشهده البرازيل من تطورات البعض يربط
بينما حدث فيها او ما يحدث فيها ولا يزال
يحدث وبين ما حدث في احداث الكونجرس في
السياحه الكونجرس البعض حتى ذهب لابعد من
ذلك وقال بانه هناك حتى تقارب هناك تلاصق
هناك شيء يذكر بما حدث في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ما علاقه واشنطن او هل
لواشنطن علاقه بما يحدث في البرازيل
ولا الزميل هاني ولا المشاهدين الكرام هلا
من ناحيه الشكل بدون شك يعني في تقارب
باقتحام مبنى الكونجرس الامريكي
واتحاد
المبنى الرئاسي
والكونجرس في البرازيليه ولكن بالمضمون ما
هو المضمون بيننا حتى للاسنان معا يعني
اذا نطلع على الورقه الجغرافي تبع المبنى
الرئاسي في في برازيليه يعني من ثلاث جهات
عنده حدود 100 و من الطرقات الرئيسيه حتى
توصلي على المبنى في حوالي ثلاثه كيلو متر
مسافه ما فيش حتى سكن ومن ناحيه ثانيه من
الجهه الثانيه في مبنى الكونجرس البرازيلي
لماذا السلطات الامنيه لم تاخذ الاجراءات
لعدم حصول الشغب ونحن نديم عمليه الشغب ضد
المباني مهما كل الامر ولكن المظاهرات هي
محقه ولكن يجب ان يكون هناك امن ايه حامي
هذه المنشات ويمنعهم من الوصول وخاصه اذا
كان في مسافه 30 كلم ما فيش حتى سكانهم
هيك الارض بريه لماذا لم يقوموا بذلك نفس
الشيء نرى بانه بالولايات المتحده الرئيس
ترامب بخمس الشهر 2020 كذلك طلب الجيش همم
الوطني
الاجراءات اللازمه ولكن عمده المدينه في
واشنطن رفضت هذه الاجراءات ان تاخذ هذا
الاجراءات هل هناك
وقتها بانها لم تتوقع بان يكون هناك اعداد
غفيره بان تكون النيه خاصه همم الشياح
الكابيتال ولكن سيد توم المقاربات حتى
طالت بعض المقربين من ترامب يعني مثلا
كبير الخبراء الاستراتيجيين في البيت
الابيض فتره ترامب واللاتي طلته كذلك
اتهامات في فتره الشيح الكابتل عندما خرج
وبدا يشيش حتى في واقعه برازيل حدث نفس
الشيء كان هناك كانت لديه منصه لديه
لما اسماء بالربيع البرازيلي وبدا يجيش
وبدا حتى من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يدعو برازيليين للخروج ولا الاحتجاج ما
تفسير ذلك
التويتر والفيسبوك وجوجل للانتخابات في
الولايات المتحده وراين نفس الشيء حصل
بالنسبه للانتخابات
الفتره وراينا اليوم من بعد ما السيد الى
الماسك اشترى منصه التويتر تويتر
[موسيقى]
عن النفس من قبل
همم اليمين ال ال الذي يريد ان تعلق على
موضوع بانن سيتم فقط لا افهم لانه الباص
يعني هل يمكن ان تكون مصادفه ان يتحدث
بنفس الشكل بنفس الكلمات بنفس الطريقه قبل
اجتياح الكابيتل وقبل اجتياح الكونجرس
البرازيلي
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده ضد الراي
اليمين الامريكي كذلك حصل ودعاهم الى ربما
الى مظاهرات بالانتخابات المزيفه ولكن
احنا كمان هل هذه الاجراءات اللي عم بتصير
رياض عمل تطورات اللي عم بتصير اليوم هي
كمان لعبه داخليه من قبل من جهات معينه
مثلا 2016 محاوله انقلاب بتركيا هو كان
منه هو من عيله المطار هذا الانقلاب اما
ال- اللي حصل بعد ما بنعرف اذا كان الرئيس
اردوغان هو اللي قام بهذا الكلام لتفريخ
المعارضه من ضمن المراكز هل هناك
بخصوص هذا الموضوع ما حدث في تركيا وستبقى
كذلك حتى تساؤلات بخصوص ما حدث في
الكابيتل واليوم نناقش البرازيل همم سيد
هاني هل ترك في بان هناك شيئا داخلي همم
يحاك في الداخل لمحاوله فرز اعاده
الانتخابات او تذهب الى اعتقاد كما يرى
البعض بان هناك تدخل خارجي بان ما يحدث في
البرازيل غير مجرد من التدخلات خارجيه
بشكل غير مباشره او حتى بشكل مباشر لكن ما
تم ما يمكن ان نضعه ضمن اطار هو حاله من
الاحتجاج وحاله من الاحتقان عاشها ويدوب
بعد ان حاول بكل الطرق استجداء الجيش
وحاول منه خلال التجمعات يحاول من خلال
التظاهرات وفي اخر المطاعم وعند كلمه
الوداع بكيه بكى الرئيس
معلنه بشكل غير مباشره
اعتقد بان ما حصل هو امر تردد فعل من قبل
الاشخاص المؤيدين له على الارض وحاولوا
كمحاوله اخيره باستعاده السلطه كما يرون
من خلال
الدخول وتعطيل المؤسسات الحكوميه بشكل خاص
ومؤسسات لصنع القرار بشكل عام في البرازيل
لكن كما قلت لك لا يعني جميع يستبعد ان
تكون هنالك
مؤامره او شده مؤامره يكون فيها طرف
اليسار المدعومه
بيمثل رئيس دوله سيلفا هو طرفا بهذه
المؤامره
الخارجيه سيد هاني هل هناك في داخل
البرازيلي من يذهب اعتقاده بان هناك شيء
يحاك من الخارج
ين الكفر بالحقيقه للرئيس الجاهيل جميع
الدول عند الاعلان على النتائج الرئاسيه
وفوز الرئيس دولار فقط
ولم يكن المرحبا به وعلا كانت شبه سيئه
بكثير من الدول وحتى من الدوله الولايات
احد الامريكيه وعلاقته مع بعضنا وعلاقته
مع الحكومه الحاليه اليست علاقه جيده
وهو يمثل امتداد وجسر
في في المنطقه ايضا مع الصين ايضا مع مع
فرنسا ومع اوروبا اذا على العكس تماما
وعند حصول كل ما حدث من اقتحامات في ليله
الامس خرجت الدول جميعها داعمه لنتائج
الانتخابات
لذلك يعني استبعد كل البعد ان يكون هنالك
مؤامره او اي خيوط خارجيه كانت تدفع لحدود
ولكن سيد هاني من يطرح فكره الخارجيه لا
يتحدث عن دعم لولا ده سيلفا او لبوسونارو
هو يتحدث عن طرف خارجي يطمح لاحداث فوضى
في داخل البرازيلي لسببا او لاخر والسبب
سيئتهم الذي طرحه البعض هو مجموعه بريكس
همم
همم مجموعه بريكس هذا التي تضم البرازيل
والتي تضم كذلك روسيا التي تشهد حربا او
التي بدات بعمليه عسكريه يقول البعض
دفعتها لها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الصين كذلك التي همم بدات تتحرش بها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه همم في علاقه
مع احداث تايوان والان تاتي البرازيل هل
هي صدفه كذلك بان تكون هذه المجموعه التي
تخطط لمحاوله تقويض الهيمنه الامريكيه في
كل مره تشهد دول من دول هالطربات بهذا
الحجم
لا انا لا اتصور لانه
الرئيس لولا هو من معروف من اليسار
المتضامن مع روسيه المتضامن مع الصين بقى
واذان هؤلاء الدوله
العمل الذي حصل من الاتحاد الذي حصل انهار
امس ولكن من الناحيه القانونيه اليوم انه
الرئيس
بولو موجود في الولايات المتحده منذ حوالي
10 ايام 18 يوم واذا كان هنالك من ملاحقه
له في الداخل في القانون ال- ال- ال-
اتحدث على محاوله امريكيه لاضعاف دول
مجموعه بريكس هذا هو السؤال
ادانت هذه الحادثه والدوله الامريكيه هي
يعني من جانب بولسيناري وخاصه اداره
الرئيس بايدا هي كانت الاثاث ضد بول
سيناره الرئيس السابق يعني انا ما بفهم مش
عم بقدر يستوعب خلل من الاداره الامريكيه
لهذا الموضوع انا اتصور انه ربما يكون
هنالك شيء ما لتطهير ان كان في الجيش في
وتنظيف في الجيش البنزويلي البرازيلي
والقضاء البرازيلي ربما رح ننطر الايام
والاسابيع القادمه حتى نرى ماذا سيفعل
الرئيس لولا بهؤلاء العناصر
او في خضم هذه الاحتجاجات وهذا التصعيد
حاليا ما ما يتم تداوله في الاعلام وهو
دائما يكون مؤثر في شارع البرازيلي هو
دعوه الى التهدئه وذلك من خلاله اعلان
الصحف بجميع عناوينها بان المخربين هم
ليسوا ممثلين عربي
الاطراف لا يرغب بصعيد الامر لكي يتحول
الى صراع ما بين مؤيدين جايب له سيناريو
بين المؤيده البلد تمر بحال الاقتصاديه
ليست جيده ازمه طبيعه عالميه ولكن البلد
لا تحتاج لادم ازمات اضافيه هتحتاج الى
تهديئه تحتاج الى عمل تحتاج الى مشاريع
تحتاج الى علاقات دوليه جيده تحتاج الى
سريع يتم ادخال النقد اجنبي لكي يدعم
الاقتصاد المحلي في البرازيل قلت اريد ان
اعاقب على امر متعلق في قضيه الملك سلمان
ليس هنالك الدوله في العالم لها مصلحه بان
يكون هنالك هذا سياسيه في البرازيل
البرازيل تعتبر سلغ غذائيه عالميه وايضا
البرازيل تعتبر بالاضافه الى ذلك ايضا
للمنطقه وللعالم اي اشكاليه اليوم ضمن
اشكاليات ال- ال- تحصل في العالم سواء في
الحروب في منطقه اوكرانيا وروسيا وموضوع
الغذاء وموضوع
ذلك اقتصاديه سوف يؤثر على الاعدادات
الغذائيه في معظم الدول العالم اذا ليس
هنالك
من اي دوله في العالم قبل ان سعيده في
داخل البرازيلي وضحت الفكره ستبقى عيننا
على هذه التطورات اشكركم جزيل الشكر من
برازيليا صحفي هاني الدوساني ومن اورلاندو
توم حرب برايس وتحالف الامريكيه شرق وسطي
للديمقراطيه شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]